[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actualité à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat et que le critère
de présenter avec brigitte boucher
bonjour brigitte bonjour ta main est
notre invité cette semaine pour
reparcourir toute l'actualité et laurent
saint martin bonjour vous êtes député la
république en marche rapporteur général
du budget et c'est brigitte qui brosse
est votre portrait laurence à martin
bonjour vous êtes né le 22 juin 1985 à
toulouse député la république en marge
du val de marne rapporteur général de la
commission des finances depuis 2000 19 à
seulement 35 ans vous êtes le plus jeune
à ce poste depuis le début de la vème
république
un record vous avez été élu en 2019 sera
donc votre premier budget à l'automne
2001 mais crise oblige vous avez déjà eu
trois projets de loi de finances
rectificative presque un record là aussi
alors en bon toulousain vous êtes fan de
ballon ovale jusqu'à poussé le vice à
devenir capitaine du quinze de france
parlementaire cette aventure vous mènera
ainsi vos collègues députés jusqu'à la
finale de la coupe du monde de rugby au
japon alors pour filer la métaphore
rugbystique est ce que vous diriez qu'en
rugby comme en politique il faut un pack
solide pour avancer et est ce que vous
n'avez pas l'impression vous effondrez
un peu au milieu de la mêlée bon c'est
une image que j'utilise beaucoup dans
nos réunions de groupes effectivement
celle de la mêlée et savoir peu importe
qui porte le ballon dans un dans un mall
un au rugby peu importe qui porte le
ballon ce qui compte c'est davantage
avancé en cocotte comme on dit comme on
dit dans ce sport et ce qui compte c'est
d'avancer et samedi ce qui compte c'est
d'aller derrière derrière la ligne et le
ballon en fait ils passent de main en
main et on se fiche un peu de qui là
parce qu'à la fin c'est une victoire
collective et c'est effectivement une
image que j'utilise régulièrement quand
parfois malheureusement politique
les tendances individualistes mais ce
n'est ni nouveau et ça existera après
nous viennent parfois à dépasser un
petit peu l'esprit un collectif c'est
une tendance contre laquelle il faut
lutter et moi au sein du groupe en
général j porte une certaine attention
et bien le rang saint martin on va voir
avec vous et bien les temps forts de
cette semaine le troisième projet de loi
de finances rectificative adoptée en
commission une rallonge les aide de 45
milliards
d'euros pour aider entre autres les
secteurs du tourisme de l'automobile ou
de l'aéronautique pas d'accord entre
députés et sénateurs sur le texte
organisant la sortie de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire les sénateurs jugent le projet
de loi attentatoires aux libertés
le gouvernement défend des restrictions
proportionnée des bracelets
électroniques pour des détenus
terroristes à leur sortie de prison une
mesure de sûreté votée cette semaine à
l'assemblée alors c'était l'événement
cette semaine à l'assemblée la
commission denquête chargé d'évaluer
l'impact la gestion et les conséquences
de l'épidémie que 8,19 à auditionner
professeur didier rahout l'infectiologue
alias eu de marseille fervent défenseur
de l'hydroxyde chloroquine a été entendu
pendant trois heures au cours de son
audition il a livré à un réquisitoire
contre le système français en écoute je
ne suis pas d'accord avec la décision
qui a été prise de ne pas généraliser
les tests et c'est moi qui ai expliqué
excuses au président pour la première
fois et qui lui ai redit vous savez la
pcr c'est très simple et tout le monde
peut le faire et donc c'est pendant tout
ce temps on n'a pas dit la vérité
maintenant dire laurent saint martin
quand on entend professeur didier raoult
et est-ce qu'on peut se dire que on peut
avoir un doute sur les failles de l'état
dans cette gestion de l'épidémie
vous présentez le docteur out qui est
une des personnes auditionnées par cette
mission d'information à laquelle on a
doté des pouvoirs d enquête qui va aussi
karine la combi hier par exemple mes
preuves en et vous couvrez vous même
dans votre reportage la seule audition
de 10 les routes c'est didier rahout est
un scientifique pertinent très reconnu
dans son domaine et la commission
denquête ne l'a auditionné que là dessus
que là dessus le reste le personnage
médiatique je le suis comme vous je suis
un citoyen comme vous il en face in
certain il en fatigue d'autres je ne me
prononcerai pas là-dessus la seule chose
qui m'intéresse comme membre de la
mission d'information même si je vais
devoir passer la main pour des raisons
d'agenda évidemment à certains de mes
collègues
la seule chose qui m'importe c'est ce
que monsieur raout à dire de la gestion
de la crise a à dire de sa propre
interprétation de la maladie et de ce
qu'il a proposé pour la soigner
ça c'est intéressant le reste savoir
quels sont les passes d'armes entre me
sera août et la présidente de la mission
qu'elle est le ton employé par tel ou
tel collègue par rapport à didier rahout
m'intéresse absolument pas et si on veut
qu'on reste sur le fond laurent ce
moment est-ce que c'est compliqué pour
des parlementaires qui ne sont pas des
scientifiques qui ne sont pas
spécialistes de juger ce qu'il dit à
quoi ça sert ce type d'audition et ce
qu'il faudrait pas avoir plus de débat
contradictoire mais peut-être des
scientifiques les 1 face aux autres et
face aux parlementaires c'est ce que
prévoit éventuellement de faire la
commission denquête ya peut-être là ça
peut être une option mais quand vous
faites un débat contradictoire et il ne
vous est pas plus facile de juger qui a
raison mais vous touchez un point très
important le parlementaire n'est pas
nécessairement médecin il y en a mais il
y en a comme moi qui ne le sont pas et
donc nous devons nous avoir notre devoir
d'acteurs public de décideurs de
législateur pour comprendre
effectivement la lumière des auditions
ce qui nous paraît pertinent
quels enseignements peut on tirer mais
ce n'est ce qui est compliqué qu'est ce
qui compte dans une commission d'
enquête comme celle-là c'est de faire
mieux la prochaine fois on sait de c'est
d'essayer de tirer des enseignements
c'est pas de savoir qui est responsable
qui a plus ou moins de l'afe ce qui
compte est ce que collectivement dans un
esprit d'union nationale s'il ya une
deuxième vague
eh ben on peut effectivement évité un
confinement généralisée et préparer
différemment cette étape cruciale qu'est
ce qui se passe il ya un nouveau virus
dans quelques années comment est-ce
qu'on se prépare vraiment leur équilibre
qu'a livré aussi les réquisitoires
didier rahout a répondu à des questions
de députés ce n'est pas un réquisitoire
madame lacombe a fait lui-même le long
la gestion de l'état et on sait qu
emmanuel macron lui a donné du crédit
quand même en allant à marseille il a
aussi vous vous prenez comme parti pris
chez désolé vous si vous écoutez
l'ensemble de l'audition de monsieur
raout il ya plusieurs plusieurs moments
où il salue aussi des bonnes décisions
qui ont été prises
le sujet c'est d'avoir un point de vue
par un personnage important moment de la
crise qui est un médecin qui a fait des
choix avec son institut dans ce taux
dans son hôpital on essaie de comprendre
ses choix
qu'est-ce qui a été utile à travers ses
choix qu'est ce qui a peut-être été
aussi problématique à travers ses choix
effectivement nous ne ressortiront pas
médecin de cette commission denquête
nous sommes là pour entendre pour
comprendre et comment est ce qu'en
termes d'action publique parce que c'est
ça notre compétence
comment est ce qu'en termes de
législation pourront éventuellement
faire changer les choses pour que demain
nous soyons mieux préparé à ce type de
crise lé l'actualité c'est aussi le 3e
budget rectificatif depuis le début de
la crise sanitaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et de trois le troisième projet de loi
de finances rectificative a été adopté
en commission à l'assemblée cette
semaine il a pour but de renforcer les
dispositifs déjà en place pour faire
face à la crise et d'aidé plusieurs
secteurs en difficulté il donne aussi un
petit coup de pouce à la consommation en
étendant la prime macron stéphanie des
pierres c'est le troisième budget
rectificatif pour faire face à la crise
sanitaire devenue une crise économique
l'état débloque 45 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour les secteurs les
plus fragilisés comme le tourisme
l'aéronautique l'automobile ou encore la
presse je rappelle que l'ensemble des
sommes qui sont consacrés à cette
réponse à la crise économique représente
avec ce plfr 3 460 milliards d'euros
c'est 20 % de la richesse nationale
française
c'est l'équivalent du produit national
brut de l'autriche
c'est donc une réponse massive et je le
redis efficace qui étaient apportées à
cette crise
en commission les députés ont renforcé
les dispositions de soutien aux
entreprises et prolonger la prime macron
pour les salariés jusqu'au 31 décembre
ils ont aussi débloquer 425 millions
d'euros pour les transports en ile de
france
insuffisant pour la droite qui gère la
région l'état a laissé pendant quatre
mois participer la région à l'effort
national notamment en assurant la
continuité du service public et des
transports en commun c'est-à-dire payés
à 100% les opérateurs la sncf la ratp
pour un service qui n'a pas dépassé 30%
et aujourd'hui et les discussions
préalables ont montré
l'état le gouvernement vous même sur le
rapporteur personne n'est en mesure de
s'engager sur une compensation intégrale
il devrait y avoir un quatrième budget
rectificatif en septembre car les
chiffres sont vertigineux
le pib est en recul de 11% le déficit
public passe la barre des 220 milliards
d'euros à laurent saint martin ce budget
sera t-il suffisant ou faudra-t-il
effectivement un quatrième budget
rectificatif au moins de 7 ans nous le
verrons bien les véhicules législatifs
c'est pas le plus important de savoir si
on a trois ou quatre ce qui compte c'est
ce que vous avez dit est ce que nous
mettons assez et nous surtout nous
mettons au bon endroit pour que nos
entreprises maintenant puisse rebondir
ça fait quatre mois que nous sommes au
coeur d'une crise majeure
peut-être la plus importante que notre
histoire moderne est connue d'un point
de vue économique pourquoi parce que
nous avons arrêté volontairement par le
confinement à la fois l'offre
c'est-à-dire que les entreprises
puissent produire et à la fois là deux
membres en les demandant aux gens de
rester chez eux pour redémarrer tout ça
il faut beaucoup de puissance publique
il faut beaucoup dead il faut beaucoup
d'accompagnement et donc il faut
beaucoup d'efforts pitch est question de
la reprise nous avons bruno le maire l'a
bien expliqué 20 % de la richesse
nationale consacrée au sauvetage de
notre économie et à sa reprise c'est
colossal
cet argent on y reviendra c'est pas de
l'argent magique cet argent nous
l'empruntons nous nous endettons pour
pouvoir redémarrer notre économie mais
ce que nous disons c'est que nous avons
fait le choix de l'endettement pour que
notre économie reste vivante
nous avons fait le choix de
l'endettement pour qu'elle puisse
repartir et surtout nous avons fait le
choix de l'endettement pour sauver un
maximum d'emplois
c'est ça qui compte ça sera notre seule
boussole s'il faut en plus il faut un
peu la ferme quatre pour sauver plus
d'emplois je n'ai aucun problème à
vancouver nous votre homologue au sénat
l'ibérique de montgolfier juge que ce
texte ne contient pas de vraies mesures
de relance il trouve que cela ne va pas
assez vite il veut des mesures pour
donner plus de trésorerie aux
entreprises stimuler l'investissement
des collectivités de débloquer les
pannes accumulé pourquoi ce n'est pas
déjà présent dans ce texte sale est
présent dans ce texte et albéric de
montgolfier le sait pertinemment qu 45
milliards d'euros supplémentaires sont
mis sur la table à travers ce texte dont
une mesure inédite qui n'a jamais été
fait dans l'histoire de la république
l'exonération de charges sociales pour
toutes les entreprises qui ont été
touchées de plein fouet par la crise
c'est à dire les secteurs que vous avez
bien présentés dans votre reportage
hôtellerie cafés restaurants mais aussi
tous ses secteurs dépendant de ces mêmes
restaurants et hôtels saveurs
aux tendances en france parfois c'est à
dire on a fermé des restaurants donc on
va les aider eux
oui mais vous savez ce matin à 6h moi
j'étais à rungis j'allais voir les
grossistes mais les grossistes ils vont
pas au restaurant ils ont pas de chiffre
d'affaires s'ils ont pas de chiffre
d'affaires ils peuvent pas payer leurs
salariés tant que aussi il faut les
aider et cette chaîne de valeur
économique
c'est ce que nous faisons quand dans le
pen à faire 3 nous exonérons de charges
sociales à hauteur de plusieurs
milliards d'euros ce qui n'a jamais été
dissous qui constitutionnellement a mis
sous verre fils qui je vais venir mais
d'abord rappeler quand même le caractère
inédit puisqu'on est dans une émission
qui s'appelle parlement hebdo dire que
constitutionnellement c'est la première
fois que nous opérons une exonération de
charges et jamais le parlement de se
prononcer sur une telle mesure
alors maintenant effectivement sais pas
quel était votre question précision
finale et vous allez aider
que ce soit en termes de milliards mis
sur la table mais aussi de chômage
partiel et cela pendant deux ans la
perfusion est nécessaire à partir du
moment où vous empêcher la production
d'être produite c'est ce qui s'est passé
pendant ces semaines de confinement
maintenant justement l'enjeu c'est de
retirer l'action de l'état au fur et à
mesure que l'activité reprend mais
attention si vous retirez trop vite
cette perfusion dont vous parlez vous
risquez de faire tomber un paquet
d'entreprises et des emplois à la clé
donc il faut le faire avec prudence
moi je ne suis pas d'accord avec albéric
de montgolfier quand il dit que nous
sommes déjà dans la relance nous sommes
à un carrefour
toujours en soutien attention toujours
en soutien avant la relance et la
relance et reviendra au courant de l'été
en fonction des besoins de chaque
séquence sur les transports publics en
ile de france on a entendu dans le sujet
robin reda sur le fait que valérie
pécresse réclame 2,6 milliards d'euros
dead pour ile-de-france mobilité elles
disent non et basse et la cessation de
paiement pour le 8 juillet c'est la fin
des transports en ile-de-france et le
gouvernement l'exécutif le refuse
pourquoi alors sur ile-de-france
mobilité si j'ai tenu personnellement à
porter ce dossier en comité la
commission des finances
cette semaine pourquoi parce que
ile-de-france mobilité se retrouve avec
un trou dans ses recettes important qui
est celui du versement mobilité le
versement mobilité c'est une taxe que
payent les entreprises à ile-de-france
mobilité qui est ce qui s'appelle une
autorité organisatrice de mobilité
j'ai dit au gouvernement il n'est pas
possible qu'il de france mobilité se
retrouve amputée de cette recette là et
il faut la compenser au même titre au
même titre que les autres autorités
organisatrices de mobilité composé de
l'association d'euros elle demande deux
milliards 6 tu sais c'est parce que nous
avons proposé avec mes collègues de la
majorité et d'ile-de-france cet
amendement qu'il de france mobilité va
pouvoir être compensé il faut quand même
le dire
d'abord c'est parce qu'il ya une volonté
des députés de la majorité francilienne
deux sauvées ile-de-france mobilité de
lui permettre de faire face à ces
opérateurs financiers c'est moi je
rentre pas dans une guerre de chiffres
ça ne m'intéresse pas de jouer un petit
peu au poker menteur de savoir si je
suis trop bas ou si valérie pécresse est
trop ça ne m'intéresse pas nous avons
fait des simulations sur la perte du
versement mobilité sur des simulations
fiscales
nous avons l'administration avec le
ministre des comptes publics pour savoir
effectivement
quelles sont les possibilités de perte
de versements mobilité ce qui compte
c'est ce qu'il faut dire ce sont deux
messages 1
les usagers ne paieront pas par la
hausse du passe navigo cette baisse de
versements mobilité donc nous
compenserons systématiquement la baisse
du versement mobilité et si cette perte
finale en fin d'année venez être
supérieur à ce que nous avons pour
produire et nous compenserons du tram et
l'avons toujours dit comme cela nous
l'avons aujourd'hui comme cela le
versement mobilité finale perdue par une
offre une mobilité sera payé par l'état
et je trouve politiquement un peu
baroque devenir reprocher parce que
valérie pécresse serait de l'opposition
à des députés de la majorité un
amendement qui est le seul capable de
sautes ville de france mobilité
politique à un moment il ya un moment
l'union nationale ça veut dire quelqu'un
qui fait de la politique vous je
proposais de sauville de france mobilité
ne semble pas faire de la politique dans
ces moments là il me semble parler aux
usagers pour dire que ce n'est pas à eux
de payer la note
allez on continue les missions avec le
désaccord qui reste entre députés et
sénateurs sur la fin de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
[Musique]
la commission mixte paritaire n'a pas
abouti le projet de loi qui organise la
sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire et
prévoit une période d'entre deux pendant
quatre mois être restrictives de liberté
selon les sénateurs ces 6 ticks où il a
le goût et la couleur de l'état
d'urgence mais n'en porte pas le nom
c'est le principal reproche adressé par
les sénateurs de tous bords au projet de
loi de sortie de l'état d'urgence lors
de son examen en séance
vous créez quelque chose de neuf on
connaissait le droit commun on
connaissait l'état d'urgence et vous
créer une sorte de pseudo état d'urgence
à géométrie variable et a duré aléatoire
un texte de sortie de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire qui reproduit les mesures les
plus importantes de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire est un texte prorogation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
de son côté olivier ferrand défend un
texte qui donne au gouvernement les
moyens d'agir en cas de retour de
l'épidémie personne ne peut dire
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs que
le virus a disparu de notre pays
personne ne peut donc considérer qu'il
faille aujourd'hui nous départir
d'outils dont j'avais retenu les
précédents débats qu'il vous paraît
c'est à vous même qui avez rédigé ces
amendements suppression indispensable
dans la lutte contre la diffusion du
virus
limitation des déplacements
réglementation des moyens de transport
restriction des rassemblements pour les
sénateurs ces mesures sont
disproportionnées par rapport à la
situation sanitaire
la haute assemblée a donc voté lundi
soir un texte revu et corrigé moins
restrictif de liberté jeudi matin il
devait se mettre d'accord avec les
députés en commission mixte paritaire
mais elle s'est soldée par un échec nous
ne pouvons accepter des restrictions
excessives aux libertés a tweeté
philippe bas le président de la
commission des lois
le projet sera donc de nouveau examiné
par les députés mardi puis jeudi au
sénat avant une adoption définitive à
l'assemblée qui a le dernier mot
laurent saint martin la commission mixte
paritaire a échoué à se mettre d'accord
sur la fin de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
qui avec des mesures qui sont prolongées
quand même jusqu'au 30 octobre c'est par
nature un état d'urgence sanitaire
une restriction des libertés est ce
qu'on peut
ne pas trouver d'accord au parlement sur
un texte aussi important que celui là je
ne comprends pas très bien la position
des sénateurs là dessus juste c'est trop
restrictif de liberté et notamment sur
la question des manifestations mêmes
sénateurs notamment du groupe
majoritaire au sénat
considérer que les mesures pendant
l'état d'urgence était tout à fait
adapté à la crise il ne me semble pas
comme l'a très bien dit olivier ferrand
il ne me semble pas que la crise soit
derrière nous mais alors pourquoi ne pas
songer état d'urgence sanitaire aux
champions sentiment est que nous sommes
totalement encore en vigilance
permanente sur une reprise possible de
l'épidémie une reprise possible et
pourquoi de sortie de l'état d'urgence
du coup parce que ce que propose le
gouvernement c'est justement de
reconnaître que nous ne sommes plus
confiné que la circulation de virus
n'est plus la même mais qu'il nous faut
conserver des outils nécessaires
justement pour pouvoir au mieux préparer
un retour de la pandémie et un retour
d'une vague c'est ça qui est proposé à
travers ce texte c'est plutôt
honnêtement de bon aloi et je suis sûr
qu'au fond les sénateurs le savent tout
le monde au premier qu'on commence à
faire rentrer un peu de sauce
politicienne au fur et à mesure et que
l'union nationale se craquelle par
endroits sur cette chambre pas une
attente devraient manifester dans ce
texte le avec le régime sans
autorisation préalable ne donnons pas ce
texte de pouvoir qu'il n'a pas ce texte
d'accord vise à parce que nous ne
pourrons jo pas l'état d'urgence doté
l'exécutif des outils strictement
nécessaire strictement nécessaire à bien
maîtriser la circulation du virus et a
bien anticipé le retour d'une vague ni
plus ni moins c'est un enjeu sanitaire
il n'y a pas un sénateur de la majorité
comme de l'opposition qui peut nier que
l'enjeu de l'anticipation sanitaires et
la priorité sinon qu'est ce qui va se
passer
nous ne votons pas cette loi très bien
la vague revient l'exécutif n'est pas
équipé j'attends de voir la réaction de
ces mêmes sénateurs si l'exécutif n'est
pas doté des outils pour mieux prévenir
les prochaines crises au coeur en tout
cas des dissensions entre les députés et
sénateurs la question des manifestations
manifestations qui ont marqué
l'actualité notamment manifestation
contre le racisme contre les violences
policières mais aussi des policiers eux
mêmes qui se sont relâchés
le ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner qui était auditionné jeudi par
le sénat dans le cadre de la mission
d'information sur les moyens d'action et
les méthodes d'information
d'intervention des forces de l'ordre on
écoute le ministre de l'intérieur ce que
je veux dire c'est que si comme je lai
annoncé cette technique ne sera
dorénavant plus enseignée dans les
écoles de police
nous devons trouver les moyens
techniques ou matériel de substitution
pour que nos forces puissent intervenir
et dès lors qu'elles ont été formés à
cette technique
je ne souhaite pas leur dire c'est fini
du jour au lendemain
et donc j'ai mis un délai court pour
qu'on propose des solutions de
substitution et qu'on fasse une
formation individuelle pour chacun de
ses agents dans le contexte que nous
connaissons
ça vise à les protéger donc
l'enseignement est interdite mais la
pratique est autorisée pendant deux mois
et en ondes moyennes ni le temps d'un
substitut et plus il est idiot personne
n'envisage de désarmer la police
l'enseignement interdit la pratique
autorisée ce qu'il ya contradiction
pendant au moins cette période de deux
mois et demi qui va rester où on pourra
encore utiliser la cette technique de la
clé d'étranglement
non je crois qu'on est là encore don de
la mauvaise polémique tout le monde
comprend bien qu'il y à une transition
nécessaire forcément sur les usages au
quotidien de la police et donc des
possibilités qui leur sont donnés c'est
toutefois la pratique mise en cause dans
la mort du livreur cédric jovial
l'étranglement
écoutez le ministre de l'intérieur là
encore je vais vous faire un peu une
réponse similaire à tout à leur mini
d'intérieur a pris des décisions
courageuses
pas simple la preuve et pour certains
d'entre eux effectivement dans des
discussions compliquées difficiles avec
certains syndicats de police sur ces
sujets là on peut pas d'un côté reproché
au ministre de l'intérieur de prendre
des décisions difficiles courageuses
parce que le métier de policier et de
gendarme est difficile ce qui n'a pas
peur que leur demander ce qu'ils
suppriment les leurs demandes venant
alors qu'il n'y a pas de substitution
c'est bien ce qu'on entend s'il vient
d'expliquer que si mais qu'il y avait
effectivement un délai de transition
les tortues sur chacun comprend deux
substituts et chacun comprendra qu'on ne
change pas du jour au lendemain des
méthodes et des pratiques
d'interpellations les rendez vous compte
métier quotidien des policiers et des
gendarmes ils ont besoin aussi d'être
rassurés sur leur capacité d'interpeller
c'est normal si une méthode
deux voués à disparaître comme le
propose le ministre de l'intérieur il
faut effectivement qu'elle soit
remplacée ce remplacement ne se fait pas
un claquement de doigts n'en déplaise à
certains sénateurs ou madame la
sénatrice ça ne se fait pas comme ça
donc encore une fois en temps de crise
dans la situation que nous vivons
actuellement je crois que c'est mauvaise
polémique en faisant semblant de ne pas
comprendre comment fonctionne la vraie
vie dans les administrations le vrai
quotidien des policiers des gendarmes ne
me semble pas adéquat le ministre de
l'intérieur a bien répondu il a eu des
positions courageuses qui sont
difficiles je connais pas beaucoup
d'autres ministre de l'intérieur
honnêtement qui ont osé dire qu'il
pouvait y avoir des difficultés liées à
certaines prises certaines possibilités
d'interpellations par les policiers
gendarmes et se retrouve effectivement
dans des discussions complexes au sein
du ministère de l'intérieur
moi je ne joue qu'un parce que je
considère que si ton discours était
courageux il est difficile à faire et ça
c'est un ministre qui comprend la
réalité du terrain et le rang saint
martin en termine avec des mesures de
sûreté votée par l'assemblée est destiné
aux ex détenus radicaliser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un terroriste en fin de peine pourra
bientôt avec son accord portait un
bracelet électronique à sa sortie de
prison ce dispositif fait partie de la
proposition de loi controversée diel
brune peavey présidente de la commission
des loi est votée cette semaine à
l'assemblée nationale la ministre de la
justice nicole belloubet ci était
pourtant opposé les précisions de marion
becker les détenus condamnés pour
terrorisme devront désormais respecter
des mesures de sûreté à la fin de leur
peine
ainsi le juge d'application des peines
pourra leur imposer différentes
obligations jusqu'à cinq à dix ans après
leur sortie de prison
comme celle de pointer au commissariat
de police ou à la gendarmerie jusqu'à
trois fois par semaine ou encore le port
d'un bracelet électronique
cette disposition supprimée en
commission a été réintégrée contre
l'avis de la ministre
moi il me semble que ce bracelet ne
constitue pas nécessairement une
garantie supplémentaire ce n'est pas
parce que vous portez un bracelet que
pour autant vous ne pourrez pas
commettre tel ou tel acte à tel ou tel
moment il ne faut pas l'écarter parce
que c'est un moyen supplémentaire de
s'assurer de ses de ces individus bien
sûr que cette année lmnp un élément
essentiel même je dirais majeur de
protection
à gauche les communistes et les insoumis
ont exprimé leur opposition au texte
j'ai bien compris qu'il y avait la peur
j'ai bien compris que la peur était une
boussole mais elle est souvent mauvaise
conseillère
elle est très souvent mauvaise
conseillère donc je souhaite que que
l'on puisse retrouver retourner un peu à
la raison sur le sujet et qu'elle est
quelles sont les dimensions raisonnables
sur le sujet c'est que oui le temps de
la détention n'a pas été mis à profit
pour prévenir la récidive elle la
proposition de loi devrait permettre de
suivre les 5 114 détenus pour faits de
terrorisme à l'issue de leur peine
ainsi que les sept cent soixante détenus
repéré comme susceptible d'être
radicaliser les députés espère ainsi
limiter le risque de récidive et
d'attentât à laurent saint martin quel
est votre avis sur le bracelet
électronique vous êtes d'accord et qui
est le brevet ou avec la ministre de la
justice nicole belloubet d'abord il ya
urgence à agir sur les 500 détenus pour
faits de terrorisme en accord
trois qui vont sortir dans l'année donc
quelqu'un on a un sujet et chacun
comprendra bien que c'est un sujet à
part et qu'il ya besoin de ce suivi
après il ne fallait pas créer une peine
après la peine
ce n'est pas cela la justice française
c'est le cas avec cette proposition de
compromis qui a été fait par yale pour
une pub et qui permet effectivement
d'avoir de l'information d'avoir un
meilleur suivi
effectivement pour que au fur et à
mesure nous puissions laisser l'ubs est
attentatoire aux libertés
ce bracelet électronique je crois que
sur des faits exceptionnels comme ceux
de terrorisme nous devons nous assurer
ceinture et bretelles qui n'est pas de
risque de récidive
mais la garde et des français y fit qu'à
des français ne comprendraient pas ils
auraient raison qu'il puisse y avoir des
possibilités de récidive après des actes
de terrorisme
donc ce que proposait le privé est
intelligent c'est à dire que après la
peine
ce n'est plus la peine mais il y a
effectivement un suivi il ya une
possibilité si on accepte d'avoir ce
bracelet là de nous pointer une fois par
semaine donc c'est beaucoup moins
atteinte à tantôt beaucoup moins une
atteinte pardon à la liberté
individuelle que ce propos que proposait
le groupe des républicains mais c'est
effectivement une solution de compromis
qui me paraît silence un bien trouvé
merci c'est le mot de la fin dang tran
huy merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivi rendez vous la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de parlement
hebdo
[Musique]